there are reports audrina though that
you've been dating sean stewart we see
him in the trailer
as well it's hard being a single mom
dating
i don't want to end up with the wrong
guy are you guys
still together i mean were we ever
really together together you'll have to
watch and see
sean's a great guy and we had so much
fun i think
he brought a lot to our group of friends
and we went on a double date heidi and
spencer set me up with them and you'll
see
how it all started and where it went we
really did have the best time together
it was so much fun
are you looking for that serious
long-term relationship
a marriage again to be honest right now
that's not my priority
on the show it was fun but outside of
the show like i'm not
actively looking for someone to date or
marry right now i'm just kind of
embracing the moment with my daughter
and just getting back to real life again
justin
you do admit in the trailer that you
would like to settle down
become a dad i'm starting to see kids
and the wife and i'm like
i can handle that how close are you to
making
that happen it really does depends on
the other person right like it depends
on who you meet
i'm not going to make the same mistakes
my parents made and i'm gonna really pay
attention and if it takes me longer than
most then so be it
i'm gonna make the right decision once
and then that's it so
although i do think about it more that
i'm getting older i'm gonna pay
attention to who i do it with even more
i do feel like for you justin and
audrina people are always rooting for
you guys
are there still feelings there towards
the end of this season we ended up
talking a lot more which was nice
because there's that comfort
and we don't know you know it was sparky
it's it's something we're so
naturally good at is hanging out and
being together sometimes so you'll just
have to see
audrina i feel like you're quite the
bachelorette you have all these men
interested
yeah apparently it's fun it's
i guess getting my feet wet again to
date yeah it's
fun and just heidi helped me a lot kind
of just your feet
come on you only want to go
yeah sometimes you need that push i'm
that friend to help her
here you go audrina we did see you
actively
try to make things work with justin in
season one what kind of place do you
feel like you guys are in
right now i think justin we're in a good
place
you know we're better than we were last
season
and we've known each other for so long i
think you know there's always going to
be that friendship
whether the friendship changes and i
don't know over time you know there's
such history
so i think we're in a good place and
you'll get to kind of see that on the
show too and
where it goes let's put in real quick
last season
she was dealing with the kid stuff and i
was off of tour so
there was no like just to meet back up
and have everything roll over smoothly
was
was really difficult so now we've both
had time off so
and maybe you realized you are meant to
be together
yeah here we
go look at the time is this interview
over i gotta go
[Laughter]
sorry for putting you guys he's gone how
does season two
of the hill's new beginnings compare to
season
one for me way more intense everything
was just more intense
but just the pandemic energy
the people the crew
the settings i mean everyone
obviously was just heightened it was the
energy was very
the relaunch of the reboot had a more
like but still like it had some intense
moments but it wasn't just
always the frequency felt like like it
was wild and maybe that was our
experience
interacting like with a lot of the cat i
mean sometimes it was more fun
and more intense i felt like i could be
a part of it because season one
i was breastfeeding and i wasn't really
at a lot of the group events and i was
home and that was like my main priority
and
this one i definitely was like there and
adriana and i had some really fun like
turnip moments
and we did and then there was just yeah
a lot more intense
real moments as well